car tu aurais versa directeur général de
la folie douce
bonsoir turin vers sade vous êtes en
direct de bourg-saint-maurice merci de
répondre à nos questions
al'approche des vacances de noël vous
allez accueillir des vacanciers pour
noël ou encore pour le jour de l'an
après une année blanche ou presque dans
quel état d'esprit ce que vous êtes vous
mais à la fois vos confrères que ce soit
à val d'isère à courchevel en tarentaise
ou encore à la toussuire ou à valloire
en moyenne
et bien bon soit effectivement la saison
s'apprête à être un petit peu compliqué
il faut déjà savoir que nous avons fermé
nos établissements il ya de cela 18 mois
et que nous n'avons jamais rouvert nous
avons recruté pour la folie douce mine
de rien 600 saisonniers
qui sont aujourd'hui avec nous nous
préparons nos établissements mais avant
tout nous sommes des restaurateurs
passionné donc cette année ce sera la
restauration qui sera mis en avant et
non pas la partie festive de la folie
douce
le premier ministre a précisé que les
professionnels seraient accompagnés
connaît-il ce que est ce que c'est assez
ce que vous attendez exactement
on s'apprête vraiment à faire très très
attention avec le avec le protocole
en tant que restaurateur je ne suis pas
sûr que l'on soit admise est à ce stade
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles on se
concentre vraiment sur nos exploitations
que les charges fixes des discothèques
fermaient à partir de vendredi seront
compensées à 100%
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles de nous
concernant
on sait qu emmanuel macron était en
déplacement dans le cher récemment il a
déclaré ne vous sentez pas stigmatiser
ce n'est pas vrai vous êtes le seul
endroit où avec un pass and it erp vous
pouvez boire sans mettre le masque mais
on va essayer je m'y engage à rouvrir au
plus vite qu'est ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous pensez que le 6 janvier vous
allait rouvrir ou es ce que vous avez
peur d'une nouvelle prolongation
c'est ce que je pense c'est qu'on doit
faire tous très très attention avec
cette clé sanitaires et
j'espère que cette parenthèse covit va
se refermer au plus tôt
nous concernant on demanderait surtout
avoir des domaines skiables et qui
deviendrait et des colis de fruits zone
si je peux dire en imposant le pass
annie terre au niveau des remontées
mécaniques en plus des restaurants
d'altitude aujourd'hui ce qui nous fait
relativement peur ce serait une
recrudescence de cas parce qu'il ya un
certain laxisme sur les domaines est ce
que par rapport à vous à la folie douce
ou vos confrères restaurateurs ou vos
confrères gérant de boîte de nuit est ce
que est ce que vous craignez des dépôts
de bilan est ce que vous avez peur pour
pour la fin de mois et pareil pour payer
également tous les tous les saisonniers
est
ce qu'il ya une hécatombe à attendre
c'est une c'est certes une catastrophe
dix-huit mois 18 mois de fermeture on ne
s'y attendait pas du tout
nous avons rouvert et comme je le disais
avec 600 collaborateurs 600
collaborateurs c'est une charge de
dengue est par moments de marchandises
qui est monté dans nos établissements de
produits frais les cuisines tourner
tambour battant
on ne pourrait pas se permettre de
refermer on ne pourrait pas se permettre
effectivement de ne pas faire une saison
complète cette année il ya une étude qui
est paru fin novembre
l'étude comme corps exactement menée par
le professeur arnaud fontanet avec
l'institut pasteur qui a eu comme mois
de juillet dernier les soirées en boîte
de nuit ont fait grimper le risque de
contamination de sept cent
quatre-vingt-dix pour cent chez les
moins de 40 ans mickael pas sanitaires
les établissements de nuit reste un peu
un lieu à risque non
effectivement
concernant la montagne c'est le sujet
quand même ce soir la montagne ce sont
des lieux de plein air des lieux ouverts
et en l'occurrence donc la folie douce
des grandes terrasses très très grande
avec des grandes capacités d'accueil où
les clients seront toujours espacées et
c'est la raison aussi pour laquelle on
se focalise sur la restauration et non
pas sur la partie boîte de nuit
merci beaucoup arnaud art et versa
d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes donc le directeur
général de la folie douce